ah you ready yes we're ready eldon ring
baby likely that
unlikely i just started
i rolled i'm still alive it doesn't
count you can see i'm breathing
yeah again yeah again try jump attack
i don't think i will
i'm playing as a prophet because he
looked the coolest and that sounds cool
how you doing homie
you want me to jump don't you here comes
the plunge
whoa
what there's no fall damage i can pass
time there's time in the game
whoa
a good old sneak behind and stabbing the
ass attack
just as planned baby
jump
what
[Laughter]
what are you doing stop it stop it okay
nothing beats jumping
jump
you can't hit me
you'll never hit me
i'm coming for you later
okay
this
this game is a lot friendlier to begin
with like i expected to be dead six
times already i told you i'll come for
you
i told you bro
yes
so i'll be revived here but uh okay i
think the game wants me to die now yeah
i'm sure i'm sure it'll be fine before
we continue quick word from sponsor let
me tell you why opera gx is the greatest
browser that everyone should be using
first off gx control if your computer
runs like this
or seems like it's running inside that
here then just slap on gx control which
lets you limit the amount of ram and cpu
that your browser uses and bada bing
bada boom you're out in green biome city
baby amazing feature there's more they
got a ton of apps integrated if you're
using whatsapp facebook discord hit up
your browse right in your browser one
button bing bong bang bang you can join
opera gx server they have 500 000
members and you can talk to other people
that have a great taste in what internet
browser they use
some people don't care about it but i do
and that's design this is the
best looking browser if you use my link
in description you get the cool
pewdiepie background which looks so
goddamn good they have a ton of cool
themes as well which i love they also
have live backgrounds for different
games like there's a minecraft one look
at that live background i kind of want
to try that well look at that
a ghost of tsushima one hey
but of course you should only really use
mine oh five stars thanks guys
yeah the only one you need i use opera
even before they reached out to me i
love the music controls well you'll find
when you use it there's a ton of hidden
features and cool stuff that really lets
you customize it the way you want it and
and
have it your way basically while
inferior internet browsers blast you
with a bunch of news that you don't care
about which is super irritating opera gx
games they know what you like and they
give it to you they have a release
calendar for all the next upcoming games
what's that elden ring heck yeah they
also have a random aggregated ones which
honestly i found a ton of great games
today
especially free ones just click on what
consoles you're on and
you're good to go i highly recommend you
guys download opera gx it's free it
supports the channel i've been using
this before they reached out to me for a
long long time i love this browser and i
have absolutely no intention of
switching it's the greatest
it's the greatest love you love your
opera
thank you go download it get the
pewdiepie skit come on you don't have to
get the pewdiepie skin
just download it
what's the worst
thing that can happen
[Laughter]
bro you're useless
[ __ ] pathetic man that was a boss
is this a baby game for baby whoa
look at that
so now the more open world element which
is in this souls game reveals itself so
cool look how threatening i look hell
yeah
you are maiden
i'm a goddamn simp is that an
enemy got him zero this baby look at
this cute ass birds birds aren't real
you win this round bird week week week
oh what what what what it what it what
is he what is it
have you heard of the finger maiden have
you heard of the high elves but you
i am afraid they keep rubbing it in they
keep rubbing it in i can play the role
of maiden okay this is that's ridiculous
this is what gamers think interacting
with girls is like
uh no thanks
what happens if you say no i need to
know
you you strike me as a kind of girl that
if i don't text you back you're gonna
text me a hundred times you know what i
mean
[Laughter]
all right this guy looks tough
oh he is
that's all right i have my escape on top
of the runes baby but you can't jump
ha ha fool
ow ow my toes he hit my toes
yeah i did it
easy
what no no no no no
what happened
cyril
that does not count because
my uh uh the girl distracted me i
thought i told you to leave
fine oh she gave me a horse
whoa
you're gonna smear again oh [ __ ] oh yeah
oh yeah
oh oh you're not so smug
[ __ ]
how do i hit him
ah don't hit me like
yeah yeah
yeah yeah
ow i thought fighting on a horse was
good
yeah
whoa
hold on hold on zigzag
zigzag zigzag zigzag let's go jurgen hey
man
oh he can double jump
it's like a goat
what the hell are those
i'm sorry bro you gotta die
balls are evil
it's an onix it's a pokemon reference i
get it anything that exists without me
knowing exists without my permission
oh sh
you
finally awake
ball trap i told you you can never trust
the ball man whoa
big ball ah
no okay he's low he's low
hit him in the knees
okay
no i was so close [ __ ]
oh
he [ __ ] fell i tripped that son of a
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
epic lou
nothing
what the hell
all right checking out death hole
also known as my ass good one phil all
right locked by contraption
just like my ass okay
oh this guy's way too strong
don't be strong don't be strong don't be
strong
yeah
uh don't be strong why is it glowing
he's coming back
all right we're gonna rush we're gonna
rush
oh i'm alive holy sh
okay i'm dead i'm dead you got me fine
one day fine no no there remove it oh is
it a boss oh
oh
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh black knife assassin
all right here we go mr black in my
fuzzy i'm gonna do this
yeah and then that
and you're gonna do that that's all
right
oh [ __ ] bro your hp have bro
bro let's heal bro let's heal we're
buffalo we're buffalo
oh that is a lot of damage let's go
let's do that again
idiot
so dumb i'm cheesing this boss
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow
[Laughter]
oh it's this guy he can't be so tough
just hit him in the knees
okay he's tough
whoa
okay you make a good point
holy sh i'm [ __ ] killing it
holy [ __ ] that was [ __ ] lit dude
yeah
i took them all out new area
what what
that is insane
someone must extinguish
thy flame uh bro i got a sick r2 attack
so
you got no chance i gotta be honest with
you
wow okay you're doing you're doing that
okay
okay but check this out
yeah
whoa didn't i expect that
we're gonna fight this bus in a while
uh-huh
you what i can take you to the round
gathering place sure
people are gonna simp hard online for
that girl and you know it oh god i'm
gonna die here why are there so many
deaths oh god
oh he can heal that's illegal
so how many deaths zero zero or one zero
maybe half half
half of that stop boss i don't need them
thank you very much
who's who said that i just said that
hello
yeah oh my stars i'm so happy to see you
what i am alexander bro you're a ball i
can't trust you is that man in a chair
no it's a boat what's a boat gonna do
where did boat go cool boss
what the [ __ ]
turtle
sorry turtle i need your nick there's
the boat
[ __ ] boat
[ __ ] you both
where you [ __ ] bo
what are you [ __ ] ah this is a flying
boat how about flags
oh cool
pretty kill
a boat
oh [ __ ]
oh
oh [ __ ] guys
no
it's so sloppy dude all right it's on mr
boat man
third is flashing water
not cool man
this bus is so annoying it's all over
the place i do so little damage dude
come on
come on
come on
come on baby
so close
yeah
screwball
spirits yeah i can summon boat yes
but i'm gonna be streaming more elden
rings check out link in description
become a member and
i'll see you guys on the streams
[Music]